ALAN EUSTACE: Today, we're
honored to have two extreme
pilots from very different
extremes.
We have Andre Borschberg, who
flies jets, so Hawker Hunters,
F-5's at one end of
the envelope.
And we have Bertrand Piccard,
world-record-setting
balloonist, first to
circumnavigate
the globe in a balloon.
And together, they have
collaborated on a remarkable
project that lives in yet
another corner of the
aeronautical envelope.
And we're honored to have them
here in conversation to tell
us a bit about it.
But first I think we're going to
roll an introductory film.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The first airplane to fly.
The first to cross
the Atlantic.
The first to break the
sound barrier.
The first to fly day and
night without fuel.
-Three, two, one, go!
We made it!
We made it, guys!
We made it.
Absolutely I believed it.
[APPLAUSE]
-When I was a child, I saw my
father diving into the deepest
point of the ocean
with the US Navy.
That was actually my
first inspiration.
Today, in scientific
exploration, I want to inspire
others to also achieve the
impossible thanks to
pioneering spirit.
[APPLAUSE]
-I've been educated at MIT, and
this time spent in Boston
let me [INAUDIBLE]
startup companies.
I know that dreams
fuel innovation.
And I also know that human
commitment and new
technologies can really
change the world.
-In the spirit of exploration,
Solar Impulse intends to
achieve the first ever round
the world flight powered by
solar energy.
-It's amazing, just amazing.
-Inspiring new generations.
Bringing innovative solutions to
the challenges of humanity.
Inventing a brighter future.
-And you-- would you like
to be a part of it?
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ALAN EUSTACE: So to be clear,
this project of yours, this
collaboration, has
some implicit and
some explicit goals.
Can we start out by telling us
what the explicit goals are?
What exactly, in FAI terms, is
it that you're attempting to
do first this year,
and then in 2015?
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: [INAUDIBLE].
BERTRAND PICCARD:
Exactly, yes.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: Our goal, as
you have seen, is to fly
around the world with a
solar-powered airplane.
To do with it, we need
to fly day and night.
Up to now, I think the
solar-powered airplane has
been flying since
about 30 years.
But they fly well when the sun
is high in the sky, so between
10 o'clock and 3 o'clock
in the afternoon.
But no one can fly
through the day.
And of course, no one can fly
through the night as well.
To cross ocean, of course we
need to get to this notion of
perpetual flight.
And we wanted to have
a clean solution.
The solution's where you collect
the energy directly on
the airplane.
And you'll understand
why afterwards.
So what we did now was able
to demonstrate we
can fly day and night.
We limit ourselves to
fly for 24 hours.
The next goal is 2015.
That's our flight around
the world.
BERTRAND PICCARD: And meanwhile,
if we're here, it's
to cross the United States.
Because it was until
now a European
project, Swiss project.
Of course, the next level is to
bring this airplane where
everything began.
The history of aviation started
here in the US.
So for us, it's great to bring
the project to the high level,
which is coast to
coast America.
But of course, the goal, as you
can see, is to fly day and
night with a solar-powered
airplane.
That means without fuel.
But beyond this, what you like
to do, is to inspire people to
also try to achieve
the impossible.
Because maybe for you, it's
very strange what
I'm going to say.
But for the rest of the world,
which is not Google, a lot of
people are limited
by their fears.
They're limited by
their certitudes.
They're limited by their
convictions that they cannot
do better than what
they already do.
And that's why humankind is
stuck and doesn't move as fast
as it should.
So we want to bring positive
emotions around innovation,
around exploration, around clean
technologies, and show
that the challenges we're
facing now in terms of
ecology, environments, clean
technologies, energy, and so
on is really something sexy that
people should look with
bright eyes, and not
with reluctance.
ALAN EUSTACE: Whoa.
So all of that in
one airplane.
Well, two airplanes, I guess.
BERTRAND PICCARD: Yeah.
But if we woke up in the
morning, and we'd go over
there and say, oh, we should
speak about innovation, we
should speak about pioneering
spirit, nobody
would come to listen.
But because we have an airplane
that is really fantastic.
And the one of you who are
pilots can imagine how it is
to fly any airplane like that.
And the signature in the sky
is such a crazy shape.
Of course people are
attracted by it.
The media talk about it and
gives an opportunity to really
explain what we deeply think.
So it's an airplane.
We love to fly with
it, of course.
But it's also a vehicle to
spread what we really believe.
ALAN EUSTACE: That actually
almost sounds like a
counterpoint to--
somebody with a keyboard in
front of them can look up the
Saint-Exupery quotation about
if you want men to build
ships, don't tell them about the
engineering, but to take
them down to the shore
and talk of the sea.
This is sort of the opposite.
You're building a ship so as to,
instead of the sea, teach
people the wonders of flight,
limit the technology, what you
can do with unlocking.
I'd love it if somebody could
look up the exact quotation
now that I've butchered it.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: The thrill
of flying is a dream, also.
You don't talk only
about technology,
you talk to the emotions.
I think everyone sees an
airplane can imagine himself
being there, maybe
flying himself.
So it's really linked to this
part of the brain as well.
BERTRAND PICCARD: You know, in
my entire life, I was reading
history books about
exploration.
And I saw the power of
exploration in the mindset of
the people.
And today, with this solar
airplane, we can write a page
of history instead of only
reading what others have done.
And this is what
is fascinating.
And this is also why we want to
associate as many people as
possible to this adventure.
So the maximum number of people
can really feel they're
part of this history of aviation
and energy and
innovation.
That's why it's nice to make a
talk here, and then to invite
you to see the land, and have
you really understand what we
do and spread the words
for further on.
So it's also a communication
project, not only an
aeronautical project.
Sorry for the pilots!
ALAN EUSTACE: I was going
to ask this later in the
discussion, but since you talked
about you want as many
people as possible involved,
what are the different ways
you're getting people
involved.
So there are clearly the passive
ways of coming and
watching, reading,
following online.
Are there more active
ways you're
getting people involved?
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: Flying
certainly is the best way.
It's the way we get
most of the people
following up on the project.
And we have quite a lot
of interactions.
The pilot is connected from
the takeoff to the landing
with the ground.
Not only with the ATC, but with
the control center, and
through the control center
with media, partners,
universities, schools.
We had a lot of discussions
in, of course, the public.
But we have a lot of discussions
with the schools
and kids of the age of 10,
12, 14, asking questions.
And when you can answer these
questions at 30,000 feet--
almost at 30,000 feet--
in a solar-powered airplane,
and you can talk about this
technology, this is an impact.
And we've noticed also how
many people dream about
innovation, dream about being
pioneers in their own life,
dream about being more open
to the world, but they
don't dare to do it.
They're alone.
They're isolated.
And we also like to bring these
people around Solar
Impulse to create more
connections between them.
In other words, to give a little
bit more voice and
power to the people who have
something to say and to do and
who don't dare to do it.
So we're starting now.
It's the early beginning.
But you know how an early
beginning can grow.
We're starting to build a
community of people who like
to share this mindset and who
like to interact together.
So it must be a two-way
communication with this community.
So we're starting it now.
And it should be completely
ready for the
fight around the world.
You can already start to sign
up on our page for that.
ALAN EUSTACE: On the surface, as
I alluded at the beginning,
balloon pioneer, jet pilot,
you're flying a very different
kind of airplane
here together.
Can you tell us a bit about how
the collaboration started?
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: I think it's
Interesting to talk about our
collaboration.
Because it's, I think, also
linked afterwards to this
question of flying
the airplane.
We are very different.
I think we share the goal.
We have the same goal.
We share the same values.
But we're extremely different.
Bertrand is a psychiatrist,
American doctor.
Maybe he has more the dimension
of the humanist.
And I'm an engineer, and maybe
more the technology
[INAUDIBLE]
as we see, we influence each
other so much that he's
becoming an engineer,
and I'm becoming a
psychiatrist as well.
But the combination effect
of this totally different
approach helps us to maybe
find other solutions or
different solutions.
So when we are in disagreement,
for example,
these are situations we like.
Because we know from this
disagreement will come
something which is better
than my idea and maybe
better than his idea.
And I think in terms of flying,
that's the same.
Bertrand comes from the
low-speed airplane, but the
airplane also where you have
to discover the flying
qualities, the envelope.
I'm coming, maybe, from
the fast airplane.
But where I think we have more
knowledge about the behavior
of this airplane, and we are
somewhere in the middle with
the Solar Impulse.
So everyone is bringing
something different, but which
helps at the end to achieve,
I hope, our goal.
ALAN EUSTACE: It sounds like a
Lennon and McCartney or a Brin
and Page type collaboration.
BERTRAND PICCARD: Yeah,
you know how it is.
It's one and one equals three.
That's the best equation.
It's always been both of us.
The only one who is really able
to run that project is
both of us.
ALAN EUSTACE: Let's talk
about the airplane.
So it's insanely large.
It's insanely light.
It's powered by photons
coming from--
how many million miles away?
I'm embarrassed I don't remember
how far the sun is.
Tell us a bit about
the structure.
I understand that actually
putting this thing together,
you had to push a bit beyond
the envelope in various
materials, technology, power,
engineering, aerodynamics.
Tell us about the plane.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: Maybe to
understand the technical
questions it's interesting to
see where we are coming from.
When we started the feasibility
study, the first
questions we looked at were
the question of energy.
That's I think the case for any
airplane, but it's really
the case for this one.
And how much we could collect,
and of course, how much we
need, and try to balance both.
It was very clear from
the beginning that
we had to save energy.
In fact, the project is really
about energy savings.
And that's what's attracted
our partners.
If you see the partners we
have, we have about 80
companies large, small ones.
There's one coming from
the aviation field.
And the 79 others do
not come from the
aeronautical industry--
chemical, electronics,
whatever.
And the interest of these
people was to develop
technologies that can be used
not only in aviation, but
everywhere.
So energy savings is
the key questions.
So the consequence was quite
straightforward.
First, the airplane has to be
big and large and big wingspan
to get more lift and reduce as
much as we could the drag.
When you know the size, you can
see and calculate how much
energy you can collect.
It's given by the sun.
You can't change it.
The solar science technologies
you can improve a little bit.
But developing new technologies,
as you certainly
know, takes 10 years or more and
a lot of hundred millions.
And when you have this, you
can calculate how much the
airplane should weigh.
And in our situation,
[INAUDIBLE]
should be the wingspan
of a 747.
The power we have available over
24 hours is, in average,
the power of a scooter.
And the weight would not exceed
the weight off of car.
So that's the starting point,
and the rest follows.
BERTRAND PICCARD: So
the goal was clear.
And we were thinking in the
beginning that airplane
manufacturers would fight
against each other to be able
to subcontract our airplane, to
design it and to build it.
And they all said it
was impossible.
So we had to find people
who did not know it was
impossible, put them together.
That was Andre's job.
He brought the technical
team together.
And then the subcontract of
building the carbon fiber
pieces was made in a shipyard.
So it's a shipyard who has built
the most crazy airplane
existing today.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: But
not any shipyard.
BERTRAND PICCARD: No, it's the
one who builds the hulls of
the Alinghi boats for
the America's Cup.
So of course, today everybody
speaks of Oracle.
But Alinghi same shipyard won
the America's Cup twice.
Twice, yeah.
Do the quality of the
construction.
ALAN EUSTACE: Can you tell us
a bit about some of the
individual pieces of the
technology, what sort of
innovations you needed?
Was it just straight
carbon fiber layup?
Ribs?
BERTRAND PICCARD: Well, first,
maybe before Andre goes into
the details--
there was no benchmark.
Absolutely no benchmark.
So that was interesting.
Because we could really
create something.
We were not limited
by any knowledge.
Very often we're limited by some
knowledge, and we try to
extrapolate, to optimize.
Here, everything had to be
created from scratch.
And that was also great
for our engineers.
Because they had the impression
really to invent
and to create.
It was limitless in
the beginning.
Of course, then it narrowed a
little bit because we had to
make a design freeze.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG:
So we started by
building up a simulator.
Not a flying simulator, but a
tool which simulates 24 hours
flight of such an airplane.
So how much you collect,
how much you use, the
aerodynamics of heat--
all the flying characteristics.
Then to be able to compare
different solutions in terms
of size, in terms of layout, in
terms of shape, in terms of
dimensions.
If you look at this airplane,
finally we ended up with
something which is quite
conventional.
I get very often--
BERTRAND PICCARD: In
terms of shape.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: In
Very often the question, why
didn't you do something
completely crazy with circular
wings or whatever?
And I think the number of
unknown was so big that we
said, OK, the best way to
achieve our goal is still to
use what we know.
And the conventional aircraft
is something we know very
well-- to be able to integrate
a completely new structure,
completely lower wing loading,
and of course, a completely
new propulsion.
So that was the way we
approached that.
And then we had the weight
which we had to divide--
the weight budget, which we
had to divide in different
components.
Some of them are given.
Of course we worked
on batteries.
We improved the batteries
with the manufacturers.
We tried to improve
the solar cells.
But it's a given.
You can't change much over a
period of two, three, four,
five years.
So the materials, that's where
maybe you have the most
flexibility, and that's where
we put a lot of efforts.
ALAN EUSTACE: Did you find
yourself, at any point when
doing these simulations, doing
these equations, coming to
basically a roadblock where you
said, OK, and with this,
the propellers have to weigh
negative 5 pounds a piece.
Did you find yourself at any
of these places where the
numbers didn't work, and you
had to back up and change?
BERTRAND PICCARD: Yes, that
brings us back five years ago
when I saw Andre starting
to make a diet.
[LAUGHING]
BERTRAND PICCARD:
Stopping to eat.
For two years, in the beginning,
when he was really
involved in the calculation
of the weight, he
wasn't eating anything.
And he was getting skinnier
and skinnier.
ALAN EUSTACE: Yes, the ideal
pilot is sitting up here in
the front row.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: I get my
minimum weight there.
BERTRAND PICCARD: [LAUGHS]
ALAN EUSTACE: Right.
Yeah, I have to say, I was a
little surprised in terms of
you're trying to minimize
weight, maximize aerodynamic
efficiency, that you did end
up with what looks like a
fairly conventional plane form,
as opposed to some of
the early human-powered flights,
which was a canard.
With a conventional aircraft,
your tailplane is actually
creating a down force,
decreasing your efficiency.
BERTRAND PICCARD: But you know,
for us, the main word to
fight was "drag."
ALAN EUSTACE: Sure.
BERTRAND PICCARD: And this
airplane has the lowest drag
that was possible to obtain.
So of course, if you put a
doubledecker, you create twice
as much drag.
Of course, you also create
shadow for the solar cells on
the bottom on the lower
wing, so it's useless.
But all of these type of
things-- also inflating a
helium balloon on top of it
to increase the lift.
OK, you have more lift, but you
have so much drag that in
the end, you get all your
batteries empty before the end
of the night just to try to
move 8 knots forward.
So it's useless.
So at the end, what the
engineers come out with was
this shape that gives
the best sink rate
ever of a flying machine.
It's less than a foot per
second sink rate.
The best competition gliders
have a little more than 1 and
1/2 foot per second.
So this is energy saving.
This airplane needs so little
energy to stay airborne.
And that's how we can make
it through the night.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: But just to
answer your point before, what
we tried to get is almost
zero lift on the tail.
Because of course, if you have
lift, you have drag.
So that's the reasons why I did
for canard solutions or
double deck or whatever, that
you try to have one low wing
and only one [INAUDIBLE].
And that was also the design
criteria there.
ALAN EUSTACE: So what's
it like to fly?
BERTRAND PICCARD: [LAUGHS]
You wanted to ask that
question since
the beginning, huh?
ALAN EUSTACE: Oh yeah.
BERTRAND PICCARD: But Andre
flew the airplane before I
tried it, so you have
to answer that.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: I would look
at it in two different ways.
The first one is the
question of energy.
If you can fly, you can take
off almost empty battery in
the morning.
You could climb to 20,000 feet,
and you can fill up the
battery slowly.
And if you land at sunset, this
is energy you can provide
to the grid.
So you have the benefit of
flying 12 hours and producing
energy at the same time.
So that's a strange feeling.
That's really unusual for me.
But in terms of flying, this is
an airplane which has two
personalities When the air is
extremely calm that you can
fly with two fingers.
It's extremely smooth.
It's extremely easy
to handle if you
understand how it reacts.
That's a question maybe
after Bertrand
certainly talk about that.
But when it start to be
turbulence, you need to a lot
of effect of the flight
controls.
And of course, as they are
not assisted, you also
need a lot of effort.
So when it's turbulent,
it's a big fight.
It's a heavy workload airplane
in this situation.
So we really have these
two personalities.
BERTRAND PICCARD: And to really
explain how you feel as
a pilot inside, I think the
best example is the
helicopter.
Knowing a helicopter you are
just suspended by one point,
and it's completely
unstable in three
axis around that point.
In an airplane, it's
not like this.
In a normal airplane,
you have axis.
And you can be stable around
the bend, stable around the
pitch, stable around
the [INAUDIBLE].
And you can combine one
after the other.
In this airplane, you have to
combine all three together,
even much more than
in a glider.
And sometimes you have the full
deflection of the stick
on one side and the full
deflection of the rudder on
the other side in order to keep
the right thread in the
middle and get out
of a turbulence.
So it needs a lot of
dissociation of the pilot.
In that sense, it's
quite strange.
And you better be careful,
because there's a permanent
telemetry to the
control center.
And each time you don't react
exactly the right way, you
have the engineer screaming
in your helmet,
hey, what are of doing?
Hey, watch your speed!
Watch your bank!
They have everything.
And you say, yes, I reacted
full deflection.
And they say, no, no, no!
We saw the computer.
It was only 3/4 of
full deflection.
So next time you have to be
more effective, and so on.
And so you can hide nothing.
You can hide no mistake.
And sometimes, when I was
starting in the beginning with
flying this airplane, I tell
you, it was not so fun.
ALAN EUSTACE: Do you get to
monitor the engineer's heart
rate as well when you say,
hey, watch this?
[LAUGHING]
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: That's
a very good idea.
I think we should suggest that
for the cockpit instrument
down to the MCC.
But talking about the beginning,
we started with the
flight simulator.
And of course, we wanted to
compare design solutions, and
of course, we wanted to see
how this airplane flies.
And interestingly, flying is
usually not so much a problem.
The difficulty was landing.
And no one could land
this airplane.
The airplane was either on the
left side in the grass or on
the right side in the grass, but
not over the center line
or not close to the
center line.
BERTRAND PICCARD: A lot of
sideways or upside down.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: And we had
a lot of people also.
We had a test pilot.
We also had as advisor a former
chief test pilot of
NASA who had the same
problem as well.
He couldn't sleep
anymore, even.
But I think we understood that
the airplane had very slow
reaction, and that you had to
anticipate what it was going
to do as soon as you make a
change in the flight controls.
And at the beginning, of
course, we were always
over-correcting and getting
this airplane oscillation.
It's quite known for
certain aircraft.
And we call it pilot-induced
oscillation.
But it was extreme
in this one.
But slowly we got used to it,
and then the quality of the
landing improved.
And we were ready for
the first flight.
BERTRAND PICCARD: Now, when we
explain all this, I don't want
you to have the impression
that we made the most
difficult airplane to fly, the
most difficult airplane to
build, the most difficult
airplane to operate.
That was not our goal.
But it's the price we had to
pay in order to have an
airplane that could fly
day and night with
absolutely no fuel.
Maybe in the future we can have
smaller wingspans, we can
have a heavier wing load,
and things like that.
Then it's going to be easier
to handle, I hope.
But for now, it's the price
we have to pay.
If we want to have a stable
airplane, we have to put the
gasoline, have a short wingspan,
a heavy wing
loading, and limited
to two hours.
ALAN EUSTACE: Actually, speaking
of endurance, if I
read correctly, some of your
mission profile talks about,
in an around the world flight,
flying to the pilot's
physiological endurance limit.
I think that was the term.
So it's not entirely stable,
requires constant attention,
no auto pilot--
what are the limits there?
It is staying awake?
It is bathroom breaks?
BERTRAND PICCARD: Well, if
you're passionate enough, and
if like us you wait 10 years
to be able to sit in the
cockpit to spend complete cycle
there, or night, or
maybe three, four days in a row
for the Pacific crossing,
then you cope with it.
Because you're so excited to
be finally in the situation
you're looking for
such a long time.
But of course, if you want to
spend three, four days, you
need an auto pilot.
So the second airplane we're
building for the flight around
the world has an auto pilot
and has toilets.
This one has no toilets
and no auto pilot.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: But it's
an interesting question.
Because it's an airplane
which is
sustainable in terms of energy.
And we have to make now the
pilots sustainable.
So we know how to harness the
energy of this airplane, with
the batteries, with how much
we collect we use.
And we have to do it the same
of the human dimension.
And that's true in
life as well.
I'm sure you guys, you're
involved in the long-term
project, difficult project,
you can get exhausted.
So we have to know how much
efforts you can put, how you
will rest, how you keep all your
functions working well.
And that's extremely acute when
you do it five days, five
nights in an airplane, alone.
So it's an extraordinary
learning on the
human point of view.
BERTRAND PICCARD: And Andre's
spent already 72 hours in the
flight simulator last year in
order to train all these, the
sleep cycles, he was monitored
completely with
electroencephalogram, and he
had electrodes everywhere.
I should do it soon,
in December.
[LAUGHING]
BERTRAND PICCARD: And that was
interesting, to see how in the
beginning it can seem hard.
And after one or two days, you
get into this new pace of
flying the plane, of taking
little power naps every couple
of hours, few minutes.
And I think you were sustainable
at the end.
You could have carried on
a couple days like this.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: Well, we
measured the reaction times,
we measured through different
gains, to see, in fact, if you
keep the same concentration.
And there it was very stable
over the 72 hours.
I think I could have
continued.
But it's hard to find
your own way.
Because I think we are all
different with sleep.
So my strategy works
maybe well for me.
Bertrand will certainly
find another strategy.
You may have to find
another one.
So it's a personal discovery.
ALAN EUSTACE: Yeah, you don't
have business class in your
plane, do you?
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: But that's
the difference between the
first and the second airplane.
As you mentioned, the
first airplane is a
very bad economy class.
And for the second airplane,
which is under construction
now, we'd like to have at least
a good business class,
it not the first class.
ALAN EUSTACE: OK, excellent.
So things like pressurization,
for example,
in the second airplane.
Let's shift over to the
differences between--
the first airplane
taught you a lot.
Second airplane, you're now
working with some proven
structures, some proven
flight dynamics.
But you have some
new challenges.
Like, for example,
pressurization--
that takes power.
BERTRAND PICCARD: We
don't pressurized.
ALAN EUSTACE: You don't
pressurize?
Not numbered.
BERTRAND PICCARD: No, we have
the flight profile where the
airplane climbs during the
entire day, and then reaches
the maximum altitude just
before the sun is not
efficient anymore.
And then we start to descend.
With all this altitude that
is potential energy
that has been stored.
So the first four to five hours
of the night are for
free in terms of energy.
And then we continue with the
batteries with until next
sunrise rise, and then
we start again.
Which means that the
pressurization would just be
useful for, probably, four
hours, which we can cope very
well without pressurized
cockpit.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: The real
reason is also technical.
We could pressurize.
But if you pressurize, as you
want to exit the airplane in
flight, which is always a
possibility in an experimental
airplane, it's very difficult
to achieve.
We have an exit door that
you can open quickly.
And that allows you to go out
with a parachute and with all
your equipment you need--
a life raft and so on.
So this was too big
a requirement.
If we would have built a normal
airplane, I think we
had have had the weight budget
for pressurized cabin, but
with very, very small entry
doors or doors to get out in.
ALAN EUSTACE: OK.
So what altitudes are we
talking about here?
Tell us about a typical mission
profile, let's say,
for the United States flight,
and then for the world flight.
Take off at some time, climb to
which altitudes, et cetera.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: Every day we
climb to close to 30,000 feet.
ALAN EUSTACE: And you're doing
that just on oxygen?
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: Which is
with oxygen, exactly.
It's also the altitude at which
you can cope with oxygen
quite well if you're
not pressurized.
If you're above this altitude,
at a certain stage you need
pressurized oxygen, which is
slightly more difficult.
Of course, if you have a small
difficulty with the oxygen
system, the time that you have
available to use a safety
system or another system or
backup solutions is more and
more smaller.
I think it's 30,000 feet,
you talk about
something like half a minute.
Which is already short to
understand that you have a
difficulty and that you have to
switch to something else.
So that's some kind of a safety
that we have defined
for ourselves.
And every night we will go
down to a lower level.
This depends on meteorology.
It depends on the time
of the year.
Are the batteries full?
The goal is to be around
10,000 feet at night.
It can be lower, depending
on the situation.
ALAN EUSTACE: So you have
20,000 feet of potential
energy, coast down to 10,000--
air is nice and thick there--
hit the go buttons, accelerate
to a blinding--
30 knots, was it?
AUDIENCE: 35
ALAN EUSTACE: A blinding 35
knots, blown back in the seats
by the g-forces, power along
there at that altitude until
the sun is up a few degrees,
high enough to start fueling
the batteries and climbing.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: Exactly,
and you start to gain.
But you keep the same speed,
which you developed your own
speed, which is 25 knots.
You keep this speed because you
want to make sure that you
have the maximum energy
available.
ALAN EUSTACE: Sure.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: I think every
morning you have some
kind of degree of suspense.
ALAN EUSTACE: [LAUGHS]
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: Is the battery
going to have enough
energy to bring you
to the sunrise?
And the sunrise is not
when you see the sun.
The sunrise is about 1 and 1/2
hours later, when it's high
enough to produce and to provide
enough energy to the
solar cells.
ALAN EUSTACE: You can't
just like roll 90
degrees to the side.
BERTRAND PICCARD: One technology
you would be
interested in is the way to
make our oxygen system
sustainable.
We're working now on a little
turbine turning 500,000 RPM.
And we developed 100
to 120 watts.
So very small energy needs.
And this pressurization against
the membrane allows to
extract the oxygen
out of the air.
So we don't need to take off
with lots of oxygen in tanks,
which are very heavy.
We just produce our
own oxygen--
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: With
the solar cells.
BERTRAND PICCARD: --during
the fight.
ALAN EUSTACE: This is something
that you've
developed for the--
BERTRAND PICCARD: For
the second airplane.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: Yeah,
with partners.
Something which was required.
ALAN EUSTACE: Excellent.
I want one.
BERTRAND PICCARD: So we can
produce our oxygen.
We can recycle water.
There will just be the foot that
will not be completely
sustainable.
So we have learn--
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: How to
grow our own salads.
ALAN EUSTACE: Yes.
[LAUGHS]
I know someone you can
talk to about that.
But we'll take that offline.
So on the mission, again-- the
US mission is sort of scaling
up towards the world mission.
You've got a fairly massive
ground control, mission
control, looking at weather,
telemetry, all things.
Can you tell us a bit what
you're looking at?
What your contingencies are?
Your jet stream shifts, some new
country decides that it's
not friendly with
you anymore--
what sort of factors are
you working with?
BERTRAND PICCARD: For flight
permissions, it's quite easy
to be Swiss and to have a
Swiss-registered airplane.
ALAN EUSTACE: [LAUGHS]
BERTRAND PICCARD: This I tell
you, neutral country, normally
we have permissions
from everyone.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: Meteorology,
of course, is a very important
part of it.
And we are training since six
years now, every year.
So we fly around the world every
spring or summer, using
the meteorology of the year,
using simulation tools.
In fact, for the mission control
center, they have a
blip on the screen.
If the blip comes from the
airplane over the Pacific or
it comes from a computer,
doesn't make a difference.
So we have a simulating tool
which is precise enough to
make sure that we can integrate
the current
meteorology and have this
airplane fly, for example,
over the Pacific.
That's what we are doing now.
It's the right time to
cross from China
to the United States.
So we are using the real
meteorology to see
if we can make it.
If we can predict the
methodology well, then you can
compare it with satellite
pictures and all the
information which
are available.
So these people make the routine
of the airplane.
These people will choose the
time of departure and the way
to proceed, and eventually an
alternate if the alternate is
possible and it is existing,
which, of course, not the case
over the oceans.
ALAN EUSTACE: We talked
about this before.
You've often described Solar
Impulse as a flying
laboratory.
You're pushing the limits
on all of these things--
so on materials, on meteorology,
on flight,
planning on aerodynamics.
Are you actively talking to
people about spinoffs,
commercial applications?
Your little oxygen thing
sounds like it might be
popular among us unpressurized
aircraft people.
BERTRAND PICCARD: There
are a lot of spinoffs.
But what we have to understand
is that on one side, it's
clear that every partner working
with us in his field
is making spinoffs.
We have the best electrical
engine of today, the thinner
solar cells of today, the best
batteries of today, the best
insulation of today.
Of course, all these partners
providing this, testing it
with us are putting
it on the market.
For example, the polyurethane,
a very high density and light
weight that we have to put in
the batteries is now going to
be on the market, probably, for
75% of the refrigerator
constructors in order to save
energy in refrigerators.
So this brings really to one of
the goals of the project.
We were saying in the beginning
how important it was
to motivate people, to think of
the box, to be pioneers, to
be innovators, but it's
also very practical.
It's not only philosophical.
With the technologies we have
on board with Solar Impulse,
we can clearly say that if
they were used massively
everywhere in the world, we
could, today already, without
additional innovation, divide by
two the fuel consumption of
the world, and provide
half of the rest
with renewable sources.
So we could shift from 100%, or
almost 100%, oil world to a
25% oil world.
And the technologies exist.
We use them.
And what we hope is that maximum
number of people are
really going to implement this
on the market, and that it
doesn't stay just in startups,
in laboratories of
universities, or corporations
who develop it, but they don't
find a market for it.
ALAN EUSTACE: Excellent.
So dot org energy team,
you're taking notes?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ALAN EUSTACE: Thank
you, Yulia.
BERTRAND PICCARD: Just one
more word for you.
You know what is lacking in this
world now is really the
political will to go into
that direction.
It is still fashionable to have
cars that have too much
gasoline per mile, houses
that are not insulated.
All this is common.
And here is the way that we
really have to push the
politicians into in terms of the
encouragement, incentives,
or maybe regulation.
Because the solutions exist.
And we just need to push maybe
a little bit people to make
the first step and use that.
So we work also a lot
with the political
world with Solar Impulse.
It gives us the possibility to
meet a lot of politicians,
heads of states,
parliamentarians.
And they seem to be quite
motivated after
they see the plane.
It gives them arguments
to then speak to other
politicians who makes
the regulation.
ALAN EUSTACE: Mark has some
questions from the Dory.
AUDIENCE: First of
all, [FRENCH].
Thank you for having spent
the time with us here.
So actually, I'll start with
my own question first.
[LAUGHS]
Since you're going to have to be
flying a long time, do you
have a special allowance to use
drugs to keep you awake
that you're not supposed
to take as a pilot?
Or how are you planning to stay
awake besides just sheer
excitement?
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: So we tried,
as I tried to explain at the
beginning, to make these
pilots sustainable.
And sustainability is really
a lot of perspective.
So there's different methods.
I do a lot of yoga and
meditation, so I use that in
the airplane.
That's what I also used
when I did my 72-hour
flight in the simulator.
Bertrand is using other
techniques for that that he'll
certainly use when he does
his training in the
simulator this fall.
So that's how we think we try
to cope with these questions
and not using substance.
AUDIENCE: Someone's asking, "The
weather is a major factor
in planning in around
the world flights.
Please talk about how you're
planning on doing it." And I
guess a follow up question that
goes together for me is,
if your plane does 25 knots,
with a good wet headwind,
you'll actually be going
backwards, unless you're
flying with a jet stream going
eastbound and taking it.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: We have the
man who has the record flying
backwards next to me--
the world record!
BERTRAND PICCARD: Well, it's
true, when I came back from
Morocco to Spain, I was not
allowed to arrive in Madrid
before midnight because of
international commercial airline.
So if I was going with the
winds, I would have
come far too early.
And then waiting there, I would
have drifted to Barcelona.
So the team sent me on another
path to Portugal, on low
level, and asked me to climb.
And then I was headwind with a
wind that was faster than me.
And I drifted back to Madrid.
I was facing a beautiful sunset
to the west, and I was
drifting through the east.
So it was a perfect way to do.
But it's quite strange.
In the beginning, you just have
to understand that to
follow your line on the GPS,
you have to turn left to go
right and to turn right
to go left.
And once you understand
that, it's fine then.
[LAUGHING]
BERTRAND PICCARD: But you just
have also to cope with the
anxiety of the guys in
the control center.
AUDIENCE: Is it fair to say that
basically, even though
you're not flying a balloon, you
have 25 knots of airspeed,
or really, when you're
at 25,000 feet, it's
not airspeed at all.
So are you just following the
jet stream and any kind of
weather pattern that will
push you to where
you're trying to get.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: We
try to avoid them
because they may be turbulent.
And we try to get the good
meteorology, which is a
certain meteorology.
So that's not necessarily where
the jet streams are.
So maybe we have them,
maybe not, but it's
not the goal by itself.
And if you look at the
Pacific, normally the
situation is such that the wind
at the upper level of
west to east--
favorable.
But you have the trade winds,
which are at low altitudes, at
about flight level 100, which
are on the other side.
So what we may do and may
experience is to fly forward
during the day when we climb
and backwards and
be during the night.
And hopefully, the daily flight
is going to be a bit
longer than the night flight.
[LAUGHING]
BERTRAND PICCARD: And the result
is that maybe when I
flew around the world in my
balloon, it took less time
than what we're going to
do with our plane.
Because with a balloon, you
put yourself in the jet
stream, the c the jet stream.
You stay up day and night.
And the average speed
around the world was
60 miles per hour.
AUDIENCE: [WHISTLES]
OK.
BERTRAND PICCARD: The fastest
parts over the Atlantic was
234 kilometers per hour.
AUDIENCE: [WHISTLES]
BERTRAND PICCARD: That's
131 knots.
It's 160 miles per hour--
165 miles per hour.
Fortunately no speed limit.
[LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: So the next question
that's also related is, "How
long do you expect the flight
around the world to take?"
Which is also related to,
do you have a route?
Do you know what you're
expecting to be doing?
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: So close to
the balloon flight in the end.
So about 20 flying days.
It can be more, it can be less--
it depends on the wind.
But this will be spread over
a certain period of time.
Because we'll be landing in
the larger countries.
And everywhere where we land
there is a strong interest.
Right now, when we do our
stops through the United
States, there is an interest for
us to stay, to present, to
talk, to meet, to have
educational events.
So the total flight may take
about two to three months.
AUDIENCE: How much energy does
the plane use in flight?
What would be the equivalent
chemical energy
in gallons per hour?
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: We are not
so used with using fuel, so
it's in translation, which
is difficult to make.
But if you talk about kilowatts
or horsepower, but I
mean what our kilowatts are, the
power we use for the night
flight, it's about
8 kilowatts.
so if you multiply this by 24,
you get, more or less, the
energy, plus, I guess, what you
lose in climbing and in
going down.
You get something like 240
kilowatt hours, which is the
total energy we collect and we
use over 24 hours with the
first airplane.
BERTRAND PICCARD: When the
batteries are full, we have 85
kilowatt hours at
our disposal.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: So this 240,
that's about a third for
battery, a third for flying,
and a third for climbing.
BERTRAND PICCARD: But it's clear
that the challenge to
have batteries rather
than kerosene.
Is very high.
Because one pound of kerosene
gives you the same energy than
35 pounds of batteries.
So it's absolutely clear that
kerosene is the most efficient
way to fly--
on the short term.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG:
It's efficient.
But the transformation of this
type of energy into propulsion
energy, of course,
is much worse.
So this ratio of 1 to 35
translates to something like 1
to 10 if you see how efficient
electric motors are and how
inefficient thermal engine is.
ALAN EUSTACE: Before we break
for the buses, any last words
you'd like to share?
Messages of inspiration?
BERTRAND PICCARD: Well, we've
talked a lot about Solar
Impulse, because maybe Solar
Impulse is new for you.
But for us, coming
from Switzerland,
it's great to be here.
It's great to visit you.
It was great to have the visit
of Larry Page last Saturday
and to be in the
Silicon Valley.
Because when we speak
of innovation,
for you it's obvious.
We even see the trees
climb higher here
than anywhere else.
So of course everything
grows here.
All the ideas grow.
And it's absolutely
fascinating.
And we're really happy to be
here and to share our passion
of this airplane and this
philosophy of flight and
energy with as many people
as possible.
So it was great to
meet you all.
And it's going to be really fun
for us to present you the
plane in the next 30 minutes.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: And we hope we
can learn also a lot about
what you guys are doing.
Because I think it's
fascinating.
It's, for us, also extremely
useful for own goals.
So if we could know more about
what you do and how we can use
that, that would be
great as well.
Thank you for very much.
BERTRAND PICCARD: Yes, because
we had some discussions with
several of your different
departments on how to maximize
communication between Google,
between Solar Impulse.
I don't know if you heard
a little bit about it.
But there different ideas
going around through the
Google hang around, the
Google [INAUDIBLE]
on your website.
We'll see what comes out of it,
but I'm sure something is
growing fast.
And I hope it's going to be
ready already for the
[INAUDIBLE].
ALAN EUSTACE: Andre,
Bertrand, [FRENCH].
Thank you so much for
being with us.
BERTRAND PICCARD: It
was a pleasure.
ALAN EUSTACE: And we'll work
gather over at the roundabout
for the bus tour.
Thanks again.
[APPLAUSE]